so I really went back and forth about
whether to even do this story today
about how there still is no connection
between undocumented immigrants and
criminality because on the one hand
we've already covered this story it's
sort of obvious that this is the case
but there are still so many people who
believe deeply believe that undocumented
immigrants are more likely to commit
crimes in the United States so
ultimately I made the case that it is
worth debunking once again and before I
even tell you about the new report let's
just remind ourselves of some of the
obvious realities coming to the United
States illegally is illegal it can be a
misdemeanor or a civil infraction
depending on whether you've overstayed a
visa or are crossing the border without
permission that's not what's at issue
here okay what is that issue here is
whether undocumented immigrants do or do
not commit more crime than native-born
Americans or more crime than legal
immigrants to the United States and we
hear a lot of specific anecdotes from
Donald Trump and right-wingers who have
propagandized around this about crimes
committed by undocumented immigrants and
of course in a country this big there
are examples of everything but this is
important because our policy towards
immigration would be different depending
on whether or not undocumented
immigrants actually are more likely to
commit violent crime and property crime
in the United States but this is pretty
obvious undocumented immigrants know
that they are undocumented they know
that if they get into trouble with the
authorities if they come to the
attention of law enforcement not only
could they suffer the penalties for the
crime that they commit but they could be
deported they could get in trouble for
being undocumented so why would a group
that knows they have an extra incentive
to stay off the radar of law enforcement
why would they commit crimes at a higher
rate than native-born Americans and
legal immigrants and attract the
attention of law enforcement yes we know
that poverty and crime are connected
many undocumented immigrants are poor
but the research has shown for a long
time that undocumented immigrants aren't
more likely to be violent criminals and
yet again we have a new study with
Pew data Pew Research Center data
analyzed by the Marshall project what
tells us that undocumented immigrants
don't increase crime rates whether or
not undocumented immigration to a metro
area increased the crime rates have
continued to slowly decline more or less
equally and in fact there are many areas
with more undocumented immigration that
have had even larger decreases in crime
even though it's by a small amount and
maybe not statistically significant now
this is not to argue that we shouldn't
deal with undocumented immigration which
is still a crime right although it's
only a civil infraction or a misdemeanor
again depending on whether you're
talking about an overstayed
crossing the border without permission
but we cannot allow this discussion to
be framed as we have a crisis of violent
undocumented immigrants in the United
States because we don't and this is
actually the epitome of how the
Republican Party often very successfully
influences public opinion the principle
is they take an anecdote and they
exploit it to make people scared or
angry and to eventually support bad
policy policy that doesn't actually make
sense so let me do an analogy first to
abortion they come out they say extreme
late term abortions have to be stopped
Democrats are killing babies this is
horrible when you look at it you realize
wait a second extreme late term abortion
is really rare and when it's something
that takes place the baby often is going
to die anyway within days or weeks of of
coming out of the uterus and it more
becomes a question of the life of the
mother it becomes a question of how soon
is this fetus going to be determined
non-viable but Republicans use the
strawman of the post birth abortion and
all of these crazy things to justify
trying to ban abortion altogether this
is the same thing going on with with
undocumented immigration and illegal as
they like to say killed this person well
that's a crime it's a tragedy
it's horrifying okay I I would not even
think of minimizing the [ __ ]
nature of that but the real discussion
around undocumented immigration is is
not actually about crime it's about
economics it's about culture it's about
geopolitics
it's about diplomacy and Foreign
Relations and foreign policy that's the
real conversation around undocumented
immigration and the problem is that if
you actually have the conversation on
those terms instead of about these
crimes that Donald Trump and others like
to point to the outcome the right path
forward becomes one that the American
right simply doesn't want it becomes one
of working to minimize the circumstances
in the source countries of undocumented
immigration that make people want to
come here to begin with
it becomes an issue of dealing with the
economic conditions and the large
corporations that are actually a big
driver for that undocumented immigration
because they are employing undocumented
immigrants if you actually deal with
undocumented immigration as an economic
cultural and geopolitical issue you
can't justify the policies that
Republicans want which is why they have
to couch it in these terms of dangerous
brown people coming over the border yet
another study tells us it's absolutely
ridiculous